the death of sir david amos a respected
mp killed in his own constituency has
left a family in grief
and the political establishment reeling
tonight
how can the country respond to this
attack on our democracy
this is the great debate
[Applause]
this week on the great debate
in the shadow of tragedy
can our politicians be made safer
how should we treat our leaders
and has political debate turned toxic
our viewers panel drawn from around the
country and beyond will share their
views they'll have their say
and they'll put their questions to our
studio guests and we're joined this week
by the conservative mp and chair of the
influential back bench 1922 committee
sir graham brady
the former mp luciana berger who left
parliament after several people were
convicted of threatening her online
philip grindell who set up the
parliamentary liaison and investigation
team within the metropolitan police
following the murder of joe cox
and journalist jane martinson who was
head of media for the guardian
the big question facing them all tonight
has politics become too hostile
it's been one of the darkest weekends
politics have had i wouldn't want a
situation where people having to go
through getting scammed or searched
before they come and talk to me we're
not going to be much good for our
constituents if we're not confident
going into those meetings if we're all
looking over our shoulder with
trepidation we have to try and strike a
balance here obviously
mps don't want to be surrounded by a
ring of steel when they're out and about
meeting the public heartbreakingly we've
been here before
that again was a moment of reflection
but also quite an intensive period for
members of parliament every time we spit
venom in each other's face whether it's
in an interview or on social media we
contribute to that and we make it worse
what the family quite rightly says we
need nicer politics
[Music]
tonight parliamentarians mourned the
loss of one of their own
we do not yet know the cause of his
death and the legal process prevents us
from discussing his alleged killer
but as many up and down the country are
doing we can ask whether our democracy
is being diminished by the ranker the
finger-pointing and now the violence
faced by our elected representatives
and if so
what we can do about it
so let's go to the wall to our viewers
panel and i'm going to
start
by talking to krisilda
basu
from autonym
crescilda what are your thoughts on this
what can
be done to ensure the attack on sir
david anus
is the last attack
on an mp
chris ilda
it's a very profound question
do you feel optimistic do you think we
can do something about this or are you
asking that question
more in despair than in hope
i think in despair really but hopefully
um something can be done
do you
worry that
the the fact that we are now in this
situation that
we have to have this conversation at all
uh is endangering
you know your
position as a citizen your ability to
contribute to the democracy your ability
for example to talk to your member of
parliament who as it happens is in our
studio tonight
yes
yes
okay
chris elder thank you very much indeed
let me come into our studio panel the
question there from christilda basu
what can be done to ensure the attack on
to david amos
is the last on a member of parliament
graeme brady
well first i'm delighted we've got the
first question from a constituent of
mine so welcome to quesilda i think the
question that she asks there's only one
straight answer it's never going to be
possible to make sure there is never
another attack on a member of parliament
what we need to do is try to find ways
in which we can reduce the risk
but without losing something which i
think is a very special thing which is
the fact that our politics that our
parliament our members of parliament are
probably the most accessible in the
world in any major democracy and that's
something that often visitors from
overseas come and talk to us and they're
astonished by the ease of connection
between constituents and members of
parliament i think that's really
precious and we need to keep it but we
need to get the balance right you made
this point in your speech
in the debate tonight
uh about our parliament being so open
and accessible what would you as a
long-time
member of parliament
feel that you've got to change or that
you've got to have
to allow that
openness and accessibility to continue
it's a very difficult question because
we've focused obviously a lot on
constituency surgeries given the tragic
circumstances last friday but most of us
spend quite a lot of time in our
constituencies we might be seen in the
supermarket we've got to go from our
homes to our cars to walk through town
there are so many points where members
of parliament will be vulnerable if
somebody seriously intends to do us harm
but it has to be the case that in
constituency surgeries uh we can have
some basic measures in place uh talking
before the show uh with philip for
instance we were looking at the fact
that um
people being asked to leave their bags
outside the room
might offer a small degree of security
uh so things which don't get in the way
of that direct personal contact we
should be prepared to consider luciana
berger
your time as a member of parliament was
to some extent characterized by
threats to your safety
did you ever feel safe as a member of
parliament
um i felt safe when we were in the
houses of parliament because people do
have to be checked to go into that
building so there are certainly some
places where
you know people will go through the
barriers but you do have to reconcile it
is a really difficult task to make sure
that we have a country where people do
have a constituency link they do have
mps that they know that they can name
they can go to other than in other
countries or i think the democracies are
poorer where people just have a list and
they've got no one who's their direct
contact and we have to find a way to
reconcile ensuring that people can have
that personal connection while
minimizing the risk and doing it as
safely as possible and my my my concern
for that is about the the quality of our
politics because i don't want to put
anyone off considering putting
themselves forward for public office we
have to minimize the risk in order that
the next generation or people of all
ages and want to be elected members want
to be representatives that we don't
diminish the pool because otherwise our
politics and our country will be poor
because of it
without going into the specifics of
your time
was there a moment where you thought to
yourself
i just can't do this anymore
given
the circumstances in which i have to
work
there's certainly some some dark moments
and i mean you pointed at the front to
the fact that during my time in
parliament i saw
six people convicted
of the threats and the racism that they
directed towards me and countless others
that either were untraceable or didn't
quite meet the criminal threshold but
you know i received thousands and
thousands of messages and
i'm i'm not going to like diminish that
because people can receive just one
message and it can have
a massive detrimental impact on their
lives and it doesn't have to be just an
mp certainly i stood in court and heard
the victim impasse statements of people
from all other fields that might have
been um at the hands or had that abuse
directed at them and it can have untold
effects and massive consequences on
people's lives so i'm not going to
anyway diminish that
and i i remain of the view that being a
member of parliament is an incredible
privilege and honour and responsibility
and for all the challenges that came
with it
i'd do it all again and it was it was um
i think there's a a lot of people in the
audience who appreciate that point that
you make and i want to come back to the
issue of social media but
let's think not just of our own
parliamentarians but there's experience
that we can draw and i think from abroad
and i'm going to come back to our wall
to our viewers panel and talk to michael
moe who
was an elected representative in hong
kong michael good to see you again you
were with us uh last week
how do you respond to what you're
hearing and what you've seen in the last
few days
um
to me it's like the
unfortunate event of joe cox uh it's
happened like quite a couple of years
ago and we see that politicians around
the world have been harassed or even
receiving friends dead threats or
physical threats all over the place and
it's it's quite common
and it strikes me as like
there are like years for the uk
or for department to prepare for
something like
measures or resources that could protect
a
politician the mps to do their viewer or
do the gp to do their surgeries safe for
instance like in hong kong we
protect ourselves by having body cameras
even during our constituency surgeries
or we request citizens advice to have a
screened room if we really feel unsafe
because like politics in hong kong is so
divided and it's just uh to me it's just
as divided as the uk so why on there
like for so long years
we have sir david ammon's unfortunate uh
incident happen
thank you okay michael just stay there
for a second
philip grindel you had the
responsibility of trying to work out
what to do to protect
people uh who were elected
representatives
other sorts of measures that michael's
talking about
ones that you think we could see in this
country
no i don't think so because i don't
think that many of those measures are
measures that mps want to have
and our challenge at the time and i
guess the police's challenge now
is to understand what the problem is
but fix it around what the mps want
because if we don't you know we can't
just change how we do things but from a
security perspective because ultimately
mps are the ones that direct it they how
they want to conduct their surgeries and
every one of them does it differently
that's that's the real challenge because
their cons their constituents are very
different so
you know
so david has his in a particular
location where he's always had it
somebody else you may have a very rural
constituency may meet their constituents
in different venues across that
constituency where it's just simply not
practicable to have the same security
measures as someone who has a permanent
residence in the city so our task is to
work out how do we make the individual
safe
in their constituency and so very often
what we would do is we'd go and do
actually one-to-one meetings and say
let's look at how you're operating and
look at how we can
as
luciano said how can we reduce that
threat indeed and the home secretary has
told us that
every mp's now being talked to by their
local police jane martinson um
as a journalist how worried do you feel
about the idea that the security for
elected representatives
is interfering with the freedom of our
uh democratic process i think everybody
who cares about democracy should care on
lots of levels which have already been
touched on you know the idea is luciano
said that this of course is going to put
off anybody from applying to do a job
which is one of the most important jobs
we have our elected representatives and
how to ensure
that access can be maintained
with constituents with members of the
media who should be able to hold the
powerful to account
with that comes the the idea that you
have to have free exchange of
information
um i was i was struck listening um to
the
the wall or panelists that you know it's
been five years since joe cox's
appalling murder and in that time
threats against mps have actually
increased
and that's to me really
really terrifying and sad that i would
hope that in five years time whatever we
decide as a country needs to be done
something is actually done to make this
better a lot of reaction i think on our
wall for on the point that
what's happened or not happened in the
last five years but i want to come to
liz lowry who um
viewers will have met before
um liz
what is uh your view on on all this
uh good evening trevor my view is that
the ability of elected representatives
to meet with their constituents as
paramount or functioning democracy
the safety of mps and their staff
like all workers dealing with
dissatisfied people must be reassessed
i was a housing officer for a number of
years with my local council and i did
loan visits on a weekly basis
every visit was a challenge because i
was actually going into houses and i
never knew who would be present in any
particular property
so basic safety measures included
checking out who you are visiting
always being near the exit of the
building and also learning to read the
mood and the mirror of the person
and my final point is that mps like us
all are human beings with lives and
families and they are elected to do a
job and they should not have to suffer
abuse online or in life while carrying
out their duties
in a democracy it's the ballot box not
abuse and attack that should be the
vehicle of change liz thank you very
much graham brady um
liz larry's point of course is that it's
not just mps but also their staff and
indeed i think there was some
applause from uh i think on luciano's
point early on that there are lots of
other people who are not members of
parliament who face this kind of abuse
absolutely right and a critically
important point to make i i think two
other things that
occur to me one of course uh it's one
thing making a member of parliament say
for the constituency surgery you've got
to think of others who may be there
whether it's other members of the public
whether it's
i always have a local counsellor with me
in my
advice surgeries i usually have a
volunteer who's doing reception
for me we have to think about the safety
of those people and i think the other
thing coming to luciana's point about
whether people are going to be deterred
from putting themselves forward from
public office we've got to think it's
not just us
making our own decision and making our
own calculation of risk it's our
families as well and i think that's in
some ways a much bigger danger that
people will will tell their loved ones
just don't consider it well let's go
we're going to come back to that
question a bit later but let's go a
little bit wider because we've been
talking about how to keep members of
parliament safe
but is the bitter tone of political
debate
part of the problem that's next
are you a liar prime minister the right
honourable gentleman's words would be
less hypocritical and absurd you cannot
get any worse than a bunch of strong as
you see the panto season
[Applause]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're asking has politics become too
hostile
i want to move on from the tragic events
of david amos's death last week and
instead
talk about some of the lessons that we
can take from his life and i want to
come to stephanie
merritt in buckinghamshire stephanie i
think you've got a question for the
studio
how can we encourage more respect and
civility in politics
thank you simple straightforward stay
there stephanie i'm going to come back
to you
stephanie's question is
how can we encourage more respect and
civility
in politics luciano
what would be your top
tip
i think
i think everyone it's incumbent on
everyone at every level to
lead by example and whether that's in
person or online they should be treated
equally and we have to treat each other
with respect we might have different
views different opinions different ideas
about where our country should go and
what things should happen
but let's engage in that debate in a
civil way in a kind way you know it was
it was only just over five years ago
that joe cox saw her life taken and we
talked about having more in common and
to engage in that debate in a civil way
and as you've rightly pointed out
things haven't got any better in some
cases they've got worse i think
again we're having this conversation and
i just really really hope and in the
wake of these tragic horrific events
that as a country we can come together
and actually really think all of us you
know what can we do
well you know what i've got to ask you
then is um
after joe cox death everybody said the
same thing we had this same conversation
kind of gentle of politics
six weeks
and we were still
in the place and i don't need to get
into who calls who what names
but
graeme brady
is this just part of politics now it's
not just knockabout now is it there's
venom in it
well the clearly is in some instances
you know i've got to say having come
today from the tributes in the house of
commons to david amos having come from
the
church service such as a full church
and most members of the house of commons
i think present for it it's actually
been quite an uplifting experience to
see
the tributes to
a very
good
constituency member of parliament coming
from across the house and i you know i
think that really gives a lot of hope
and one of the things that kept cropping
up uh was david's civility his decency
his warmth and and humor being praised
from people sometimes saying they're
shocked to find how much they liked him
um
i think i agree entirely with
luciana it's got to be a bad example
it's got to be about all of us treating
others with respect we've all said that
before and we've heard this before and
you know david amos managed to do it for
a career of 38 years i hope i've managed
for my 24 years i it is possible to do
it and i don't think there's any reason
why we can't order it all right
stephanie
what is your view do you think that
politics by which we mean the political
class the elected people the people we
see on the telly and so on
can they change
um
i think respect
when it comes to politics i think it's a
much deeper issue than social niceties
i think
certain politicians
make people angry and
they also actively encourage
division um
and
and i think there has to be an onus on
politicians to
to take responsibility for their actions
in the effects
of their
actions and
sorry stephanie there's quite a lot of
support for what you're saying and i was
just going to ask you
when you say lots of politicians um
would you like to
share an example what's in your mind
what kind of thing
um
a lot of people in the
cabinet unfortunately um
their language is divisive
they
the uk seems to have been at war with
itself since
2016 and this is encouraged
by a very compliant media
we're encouraged to blame doctors
lawyers judges
um
diversion tactics
and
it's
it's become really unpleasant
okay stephanie thank you so much and um
i appreciate your expanding there but
there's a lot of support for what
stephanie seems to be saying in viewers
panel on our wall can i see
those who think
that it is possible that we can
bring civility and respect to our
politics those who think that
we can do this
hands up
okay and those who think that actually
something basic is broken that it's very
diff is going to be very difficult to do
that can i see those hands
it's rather more rather more
graham
brady our world's pretty pessimistic
yeah um and reassure them tell them how
how you guys think you can do it you can
make the thing change well i as i've
said and as luciano said i think the
importance of doing it by example
is
crucial
i was struck though the
shots that you had at the chamber and
some exchanges at prime minister's
questions it is always quite interesting
people say that they hate that knock
about in the chamber actually
it's the main thing that people think
yeah and they could go and watch on the
parliament channel any number of serious
respectful
in the house of commons people by and
large have no interest in doing it
they're asking for more people who do
watch
the case all right you're positive let
me come back to a wall i want to talk to
somebody who is
like me he's kind of politics nerd i
think josh morrison
josh
what do you make of this
where do you think all of this is coming
from
well i think one of the things that i
always mention is role models and the
idea of
setting by example
um i think university is a place where a
lot of this conversation starts it's
really the point where
young adults start to express themselves
and when it comes to certain views
if you express certain views you can
easily be labeled as a hardcore left or
as a tory and i think the the language
is quite divisive and it's quite
obtrusive as well
um i know that
we've mentioned you know someone
mentioned previously that we've been at
war with ourselves since 2016 i think
one of the best ways to be defeated is
to defeat ourselves and i think that's
one of the things that we're doing at
the moment is we've created such a wall
and such a barrier
um you know and i i don't think you know
as as john lennon was kind of laughed at
when he did the whole give peace a
chance campaign
i'd like to say it a little bit stronger
that i don't think we are giving peace a
chance within ourselves within
just us as a country
um you know i think we're in a really
volatile position right now we're in a
very vulnerable state and i think that
to show the next generation
uh it doesn't give us a lot of hope it
gives us hope that we actually don't
want politics at all we don't want
people sat in a in a in a room with nice
greek mothers
couches to be speaking on our behalf
actually the conversations are happening
on the level ground maybe that's where
the conversations should be happening
more like this okay
thank you josh it's it's so nice to see
a young person bringing somebody of my
generation john lennon into the
conversation but jane josh's point
which is really about
essentially we categorize people
put them in a box and
turn them into the enemy
how much of um
that is the responsibility of people
like you me journalists the media um
i think it's partly of course the
responsibilities of the media i also
think i mean i was struck as well by
looking at those scenes we have through
history um through tradition and
unbelievably adversarial parliamentary
system and our media has grown up
holding these people to account by
making sure that we cover it as
two people fighting against each other
sneering shouting jeering
and
the idea i was struck by what stephanie
said that
basically it shouldn't be like this and
she got lots of support because that's
seen as populist that scene is a really
good thing it's populist we want that to
happen but then there was a point in our
history and so was bear baiting and we
got rid of that there has to come a
point where we do have a civilized
debate because these things matter now
of course we're not all going to agree
with each other about politics
even if we change our system to have
more of a you know against the first
pastor post i'm not i'm not saying
that's the answer but what we do need is
to really think about what matters and
actually giving people entertainment
being rude shouting boosterish behavior
that's madness and it brings this
country into disrepute
let's see arnold briefly
oh sorry i've got to come back to you
after the break i beg your pardon um
next
if a toxic culture online is part of the
problem
is it time to crack down on social media
for social media companies it means
taking seriously the responsibility not
to allow anonymous people to undermine
our democracy
some newspapers have run slogans about
traitors and enemies of the people and i
think that that has poisoned the world
of british politics surely there has to
be repercussions for people engaging in
what would be criminal behavior if it
happened in person
[Applause]
[Applause]
has politics become too hostile
that's the topic of the great debate
this week
and one thing that could be on the way
are tighter controls on social media
let's start by hearing from patrice
wesley
coles on this patrice
good evening thank you trevor
should social media companies be forced
to tackle online eight
um
patrice tell us a little bit about why
you asked that question what what's um
your background and why why are you
interested in this point
well i'm i'm a lawyer i was a human
rights judge did immigration and asylum
work
and i've been very concerned about the
growth of
hate-filled messages on social media
channels and i've written to my mp
who's been
written to me and has said that she is
going to ensure that the online safety
bill is strengthened uh in parliament
it's going through parliament at the
moment
but
my view is that
um social media companies twitter
instagram and facebook have a duty and
responsibility to tone down toxicity
they can do this
they can block access to their domains
and urls
and they can also
publicize those
who
post
hate-filled messages anonymously
and they should be prosecuted
okay
also yes sorry
thank you patrice a lot of support for
for you there
slightly ironic that we're on media here
but a lot of support for what you're
saying now patrice's question is should
social media companies be forced to
tackle online hate before i come back to
the studio i want to talk to somebody
who
has thought a lot about this and
experienced a great deal we're going now
to the united
states um
and we're going to
talk to uh
the chief executive of the center for
countering digital hey imran ahmed good
evening
uh imran good afternoon to you what is
your view about the issue of how we
control
uh social social media or expressions of
hatred on social media
well i thank you and look the question
is quite telling should social media
companies be forced to tackle online
hate
and that's because they've failed to do
so without any without any coercion the
reason being that
they have found it easier
less obstructive to the to their core
business which is making oodles of money
through advertising
to not curate the environments that they
administer and
despite the fact that their rules
clearly state when you sign up to social
media you are of course going onto a
private platform that has terms and
conditions those endless lists of things
that you can and cannot say on those
platforms uh for fear of breaking their
rules
those standards are both a
responsibility to the user that those
are the things we have to abide by the
things that most of us abide by
but they can also be seen as a
reciprocal right that we have the right
therefore to expect an environment that
is free of hate misinformation of lies
of violence and intimidation and they
have failed to do so not only do we know
that through observation so when we
report misinformation report hatred to
them we find that they don't take action
but the whistleblower who uh has been
putting uh has been
releasing papers the wall street journal
in particular has been covering it in 60
minutes in the us they showed that only
that facebook know themselves that only
three to five percent of hate on their
platform is dealt with even worse when
it comes to what we've just experienced
in the united kingdom
0.6
less than 1 in 100 of violence and
intimidation is dealt with by their
platform and they think
that's job well done it's extraordinary
really isn't it that we're being forced
to force them
imran those are
important figures but i guess that um
the social media companies might say
okay you can throw those percentages but
really how big a problem is this how
many people does it really affect
well i mean here's the thing that the
violence intimidation the hatred these
are their own internal statistics we
actually found those to be true
ourselves they they pushed back i mean
we actually put up research saying that
five percent of hate was dealt with they
came back and said that's nonsense we've
got our own figures they don't
corroborate that at all it turns out
their own figures said it was exactly
right so we we can be pretty certain
that around 19 and 20 bits of hate on
their platform have no action around 99
and 100 bits of honest intimidation and
they will say of course it's very
difficult for us to deal with because
there's such a volume of it well isn't
that the problem that they've allowed
for the creation of a sense that this is
normal and when you when you allow the
unfettered flow of violence hate and
intimidation on a platform that is
central to how we communicate these days
how we social mores and values then it
changes it mal socializes society as a
whole
what has changed past few years social
media
thank you very much uh imran ahmed
um
the the social media companies of course
would contest
all of this and they would say you know
their platforms they do their business
um luciana berger what did you make of
that
i think everyone makes some very very
important points
and i would attest that what happens
online shouldn't be treated any
differently to what happens face-to-face
with someone we wouldn't we wouldn't
countenance what we hear and see online
in person so why should it be okay
online we've been having these debates
now i mean i recall having them
2013-14 that's still going on and i
would agree with the question you know
it is the online safety harnessville
that's coming through parliament i pray
that the government is going to do even
more than it's already doing to tighten
up what we have at the moment because i
would say that one message is one too
many in terms of the detrimental impact
it could have on people it's not okay
and we shouldn't countenance it and we
should do everything possible to stop it
and so far i think that the social media
companies have fallen far short of their
responsibility to take this stuff
seriously so i i think we're at the
point now where it has to be a stick
rather than a carrot philip grindel was
this a topic that came up in your work
in
thinking about how to protect
parliamentarians yeah i mean it was
everyday business but an interesting
statistic for you though is that if
during the most toxic period that we
were there the four years of the brexit
debate we analyzed all the reported
abuse and threats that mps received or
reported to us and actually less than 15
percent was by social media the vast
majority was by letters phone calls
emails and i know luciano worked
together and she had some horrendous
letters delivered to her but
interestingly one of the challenges that
that actually happens is the legislation
so you know we're five years on from joe
cox we could have very easily changed
from the legislation that allows the
police to tackle it a lot easier so the
most common offense is malicious
communication the threshold for that is
a term in law called grossly offensive
and very often
within policing and within the judicial
system that threshold isn't met so
actually we really want to take it
seriously i'd push it back to the
politicians and say you know you're the
people that create the laws you need to
change the laws so that we can actually
tackle these people better
all right i'm going to come back to you
but let me come back let's come to the
wall and let's see
what guidance do the politicians get
from
our 100
viewers
do you i want to ask you if you think
that
we could
through legislation
as it were tame
the social media at the moment
or could or would how many people think
that it is possible to use the law to
uh
stop some of the things that are going
on in social media those who think that
it's that the law is part of the answer
let's show
yeah 50 of you think that that is
that law could be deployed here
um i'm get i'm guessing that quite a lot
of the rest of you think that actually
this isn't about the law about people's
attitude jane martinson
um
what do you think do you think it is
possible a to tame social media and b do
you think the law is the on the way
through here i do think it's possible to
tame social media i think we have to i
think with great power comes
responsibility and
i
truly believe that there should be more
responsibility taken uh by the giant
social media companies to what's
happening on their platforms um what's
interesting how is how we do this and
it's the online harms bill has been
winding
way through parliament
for two years without i know we've had a
pandemic but there's no details there's
no real enthusiasm to actually get some
responsibility written into law the eu
is doing a separate thing with their
digital services act we need to act and
make sure that the kind of abuse that
really can be changed actually it's
really clever that they're
these huge companies with huge amounts
of money and very little in the way of
taxation um actually employ
very powerful lobbyists to make sure
that we all think it's too complicated
to make them take responsibility
but actually it's not that complicated
it can be done
thank you okay well
let's take a break
in a moment is the political climate
stopping the best people from standing
for office
it's really important that we get good
people in public life but this is the
risk that we're all taking my partner
came home and said i don't want you to
do it anymore
i don't because the next time that phone
goes it could be a different
conversation
[Applause]
welcome back
has politics become too hostile
and is it turning people away from
politics let's start by hearing from the
wall chris key
chris you've got a question
hi panel um how can we encourage more
people to go into politics today
when the current environment really is
so toxic
well that's pretty straightforward chris
asked
how can we encourage more people into
politics when the current environment is
so
toxic luciana
and there's certainly lots of different
ways in which we can
reach out and connect with particularly
young people to
learn about politics and get involved
whether that's youth parliaments and
whether that's model united nations uh
politics courses and certainly at this
moment we've seen a lot of promotion
online of um the main political parties
having future candidates programmes and
so there are certainly mechanisms and
means and mentoring as well which can
encourage people and teach them and give
them opportunity to learn the ropes and
see how it's all done okay um that
doesn't necessarily mean that people are
going to want to so all right well i'm
going back to chris um just to be clear
have you ever been tempted
to get into the politics trade yourself
yeah so for about four or five years ago
i was thinking about it i got myself to
prove for one of the parties to stand
but i think over the last few years i've
been put off by the particularly
nastiness over the brexit referendum the
abuse that people have been put up with
and i've and i've seen your speech and
lucian i'm not jewish myself but the
disgusting abuse that you see you still
personally i i mean i was close to tears
when i watched your speech in the house
of commons and i just feel that i
wouldn't want to put my family through
that i'm i'm probably less at risk of
getting that abuse as a man and
and being catholic but i just find it
disgusting that people have to put up
with it and i applaud you
for your stance and i really hope you
stand for parliament against i think
you're a role model to my own daughters
okay we're not we're not going to do the
candidate selection here but graham
graham brady
persuade chris that it's okay
well i i think we've all got to be a lot
more positive about public life and one
of the really important messages we have
to send is to say that it is a big
privilege to serve in parliament or
indeed to be a local councillor elected
office is a privilege
it's a very important thing and people
need to speak up for it and encourage
having said that uh i'm also aware that
in my party we've got a very long list
of people who are putting themselves
forward to stand for office and i think
maybe it's less of a problem getting
people to put themselves forward in the
first place more of a problem getting
people to stay and you know certainly
i've seen over the last years a number
of very good colleagues in the house of
commons some of them were very effective
ministers uh who then they'd reached a
certain point and they left parliament
and you'd have to talk to them as to why
that was but i think it's a serious loss
so it's a retention problem but um
i think connor i could see conor um
waving or nodding enthusiastically
connor what's your point
well it hasn't put me off
public life because i've seen the effect
that
mps have had in creating things like the
nhs and really helping people
and while our system's not perfect it's
a lot better than other systems around
the world
and i want to be a part of it
um connor we spoke before remind me how
old you are fifteen
sixteen
fifteen
fantastic fifteen fifteen well jane
martinson is that that is that what we
want in parliament now
it's as a mother of teenagers
yeah i applaud comics so it's so
fabulous to hear them really interested
in politics and wanting to get involved
i think a huge number of younger people
are actually really
maybe not put off by some of the sort of
venom and abuse that we're talking about
because they have been born into it a
world in which it's normal for abuse and
harm and horrible things to happen
online but actually you know that's why
politics is such a great thing actually
i mean we were laughing earlier that the
two professions that come at the bottom
of every pole of you know respect and
trust or obviously politics and
journalists we couldn't remember who's
the bottom possibly journalist um but
but actually they're they're great jobs
they're really important things you know
you you particularly politicians have a
great role and i think more people
should be encouraged to to join and but
we have to make it safe philip you you
had to hang around the house of
parliament a lot would you advise a
young relative of yours give it a go
we're interested i've got a niece who
studied politics and she came into
parliament to work with one of the
politicians in there that i had arranged
and she's now going on and doing that
and that's her that's her ambition but
interestingly i i've done some work
for with some of the conferences and
some of the candidates and some of the
councillors and if you actually talk to
some of those people the treatment that
they've had that's what puts people off
because the the actual candidacy process
and also some of the treatment the
counselors get is horrendous and so you
know when we look at we had law abu's
review a couple of years ago about that
and that's a really really hostile
environment around being a candidate and
and going through that process
okay well it um that's a kind of hopeful
moment i'm thinking that i might come
back to our viewers panel to to see
where the mood has got to let me first
say
let me ask you uh those of you got young
relatives who would advise them it's
still worth going into politics
hands up
yeah okay
and about a half who would who would
absolutely say stay clear
okay
okay
yeah
that's not not a lot not not not so much
but okay um just very briefly graham
brady very quickly
they're advertising league law
uh law of salaries at 150 000 for a
young lawyer
why do politics when you can get 150
grand
this is got to be a personal choice but
i think for those of us many of us who
did take a pay cut to enter parliament
uh have nonetheless found it a hugely
fulfilling uh thing a great privilege i
think those of us who are able to
represent our own home constituencies
especially it's a wonderful thing and
you know i did talk about some who've
chosen to leave lots of us choose to
stay because we find it so fulfilling
all right and i'm going to come to a
final show of hands for our viewers
panel coming back to our original
question i'm going to ask you
to ask
is politics just too hostile those who
think that our politics has just become
too hostile hands up
and
a clear majority it feels like we are
leaving tonight's conversation on a
slightly pessimistic note that we have a
very hostile political environment
that's all we have time for to this
evening it just remains for me to say
thanks to our panelists here in studio
philip grindell jane martinson
luciana berger and graham brady
thanks espelier to our viewers
we'll see you next week keep debating
keep talking
[Music]
[Applause]